so what would have been a good DM that
caught your attention if it wasn't the
I don't think I don't really
want to meet someone on DMS have you are
you on dating apps no never um just in
this you walk the streets in the streets
yes I mean I like I like meeting girls
in real life like I don't really like
meeting it's it's weird it's a weird
thing to meet someone online like or on
Instagram DMS just because I don't know
it's weird I don't know if they're like
messaging me because they want to like
work or they're like trying to shoot or
they like my stuff like it's just a
maybe if I was like not a Creator it'd
be easier to like meet someone on DMS
but I feel like it's just a weird
dynamic when you have a following and
you're like talking uh I think if you
post like you like that you're the
Creator then you're gonna get a lot of
religious women
oh
wow
that made me laugh that's good that's
good that's all that's nice of you it's
nice yeah but the thing is they always
say if you could just make one person
laugh then you're doing your job right
and I just made you laugh I'm interested
though I really want to know how you
meet girls in the streets because I
think nowadays since everything is on
the Internet it's almost I wouldn't know
because I'm married and I've been with
my husband for a long time but isn't it
almost like creepy because people are so
used to it like exchanging information
and approaching people on the Internet
isn't it creepy when a guy just like
walks up to you
um I mean I don't know I don't really
feel like a creep when I do it but um
like what's your opening line it all
depends on the scenario you know I don't
know it depends on where it's at I'm not
going to like the club or anything like
that but like if I'm going to the gym or
I'm at like I don't know an event or
something but
um
I will say this though like I have like
met somebody in real life and then I go
to their Instagram and I'm like ah she's
not for me you know why based on
Instagram yeah you know because people
don't realize and I'm just want to clear
this up for the people who are listening
and watching you could meet somebody
talk to them and spend time with them
and they're gonna put on like a facade
but if you want to drive if you want to
know who they really are and what the
reality is go to their social media and
you gotta scroll don't just don't look
at the look at the three four posts four
posts before you know I scroll all the
way to the bottom I want to see your
first post do you think your social
media is indicative of who you actually
are no so yeah
but but
um but for women like but for women yeah
it's different it's different yeah I
want somebody who's good at Photoshop I
want somebody who knows how to really no
what would turn you off if you saw their
Instagram you mean like sexy pictures on
a beach or something where you're like
they're not for me yeah either that or
like
you see how they really look like you
don't want to meet someone in real life
like you meet them you might talk to
them for like a minute two minutes
you're not really getting every angle
right when you get on Instagram you're
seeing everything you know
in in person it's so hard to get every
angle yeah but it's harder on Instagram
because like in person I'm not I'm not
looking under her chin and I'm not
looking at her side profile you know I'm
just looking at her eyes you know it's
not shallow like that yeah he's not
shallow he's got a he's got it yeah and
then also and then also who knows maybe
she's posting some weird stuff I don't
know it could be catfished yeah it could
not be it may not be here
back to catch but okay go ahead no I
don't have anything well actually no no
I also got I also this has happened to
me too where like I've seen a girl on
Instagram and I'm like oh my God she
looks like so amazing and then I meet up
with her in person looks nothing like it
right at all and then I'm like ah I'm
like totally not into this girl anymore
and then like three hours later I go
back on her Instagram I'm like oh my God
this girl's so beautiful like I
instantly forget
so it's only about the looks no no no
you're missing the point
you missed the point no I got it I got
it thank you thank you thank you she
misses the point you don't understand
the point yeah it's about Humanity it's
about people it's about reality it's two
souls and two souls on Instagram
the souls don't connect them on
Instagram it's a world wide web that's
how you gotta connect worldwide that's
why you know follow you follow this
and not just not just one all the way to
the first post watch them learn yeah
watch First Impressions you meet
somebody you don't know what's going on
you're going on a journey this is a
journey you don't want smells to get in
the way of meeting someone and that
happens he's right I've seen it
[Music]